you guys have a new daytime talk show
yeah are you gonna talk about things are
you gonna talk about for example you
have a line of sex toys Coco are you
gonna like that like it's I call
pleasure product what do I do wrong
they're called sex toys so they know
that they are there but I like see I
help women find their inner goddess yeah
it's in there somewhere
what's an example of a product that you
would sell well there's there's uh you
know have lubes and all that good kind
of stuff and the couple must oh there's
a vibrator for the couple's where you
know things can be inserted but the guy
actually has a remote so you can go to
dinner or something separate
yet the picture is oh wait a minute
you're at dinner with the guy I thought
you stayed home the guy went to dinner
and he's takes it out and starts messing
around with it and you're at home like
the remotes not that powerful but we're
working on one day yeah this is a drone
vibrator is basically what you're saying
yeah great and he works it I don't write
so he likes have you done this have you
guys been in a public place and he's
manipulating the controls on the
vibrator look in a club at at dinner you
know library yeah sure no but since did
you hear about this in yeah I know no
but I was wondering what that buzzing
was now
I thought there was a helicopter moving
in alright we was hosting the talk at a
talk show always a dream of either of
you had no not after we did the icing
loves Coco reality show they said well
you've got such a huge fan base you got
to stay on TV you got to do something
say they brought up the talk show I'm
like no no hell no hell no then I just
said you know ok no you went from hell
no - ok no no it was a long process but
then I finally said most of the things
I've done in my career I didn't think I
could do other people thought I could do
it so all these people were saying you
can do it you can do it sure and we
started to do the talk show we shot 10
episodes and it's the most fun I think
I've ever had
yes you guys what you do every day this
is fun having an audience with you
you're rocking like that yeah it's fun
it beats a real job I'll tell you that
just quick if we're at a time but who
are your dream guests like ice it would
be your dream guest I like get a Barack
Obama after he gets out of the White
House so he can come in a wu-tang
t-shirt and just tell me wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]